from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between burger king and japan and the
u.s this is food wars
here's everything you can find on the
menu of the burger king in japan but not
in the u.s here's everything you can
find at a u.s burger king you cannot get
in japan alright so let's start with
exclusive burgers so here we have
teriyaki lettuce burger and teriyaki
whopper
cute
next we have
avocado salad burger and avocado whopper
ah a little cute baby
look at this
and
waffle
it's totally different
this one is so huge
and avocados tomato no tomatoes i don't
know why
next we have cuatro cheese whopper
big boy
we've got smokey barbecue whopper
and smoky barbecue whopper junior and
here is
spicy whopper
it's hot sauce
next we have
tattered chicken burger
it's got
a lot of
tartar sauce chicken crispy
burger king in japan just released a
brand new burger called guilty burger
it's basically butter burger why what
have you done
let's check out this guilty butter beef
burger first the bun is different
itadakimasu
just a little bit of butter flavor but i
don't feel as guilty as he claims this
one is guilty butter crockett sandwich
[Music]
and
here is guilty butter chicken burger
first one is something that bk has
exclusive oh my god
this is called the texas whopper
[Laughter]
two patties cheese bacon bunch of
veggies wait for it
the triple whopper
look at the size of this thing the
weight of it has completely flattened
the bottom bun and there's nothing
between the patties of meat
what the hell are you guys doing over
there next uh no the bacon king oh my
god looks to be a
pretty bacon-centric looks like a double
whopper with cheese bacon mayo ketchup
mustard they didn't mess with the
veggies thank you you're not fooling
anyone getting lettuce and onion on that
one the rodeo burger is a little guy
with onion rings
the rodeo burger yeehaw onto the chicken
let's put some here japan does not have
what we call the original chicken
sandwich and i don't know why burger
king maybe just to set itself apart the
chicken sandwich is this like sub shape
right this is like i'm holding the phone
this is great chicken junior spicy
chicken junior let's go spicy
barely registers on the spice meter wait
yeah bks in the us have something called
the chick king sandwich you can get the
sandwich regular or deluxe you can also
get the sandwich flavor regular or spicy
so here is the regular regular and as
you can see just comes with sauce and
pickles and the chicken you can get it
deluxe and spicy so we went with deluxe
comes with all these veggies that you
brush off right when you start eating it
and it is got a spicy kind of hue to the
chicken there here is our side menu
let's start with this one
we've got hot dog it's got such a big
sausage
this one is chili beans hot dog
and next we have this little guy
snack chicken
and last
we have this one
chili cheese fries
and if you want some veggies you can
order caesar salad
but my bad i forgot to order
also exclusives to the us are these
chicken fries as you can tell they look
like fries but they're pieces of chicken
no babe
you can get mozza applesauce
jalapeno cheddar bites i've never heard
of these
and now i know why
burger king in the u.s has two iced
coffee flavors mocha and vanilla
assuming that's the mocha
it's exactly like chocolate milk ugh no
oh the aftertaste is horrible what the
hell that's ridiculous how bad that is
and the vanilla
that is that is so sweet
i'm gonna keep this one
so here is our dessert menus here we
have coffee float
a little bit melting sorry and we have
melon soda float
coke float and coke zero float
and here we've got premium sunday
chocolate and coffee
and here is our chocolate sundae and
strawberry sundae
and my favorite is
this apple pie
desserts here in the using yourself a
hershey's sundae pie
this one might have uh got a little
roughed up in transit and in the u.s
burger king you can also get various
shakes
here we have oreo shake a chocolate oreo
shake a chocolate shake and a vanilla
shake all right
god that's so good the straight-up
chocolate
oh man this is trouble
wow burger king shakes are really good
i'm assuming this is just the straight
oreo one
oh my god
this is fantastic
are we all curious what a chocolate oreo
shake tastes like
wonder no more
good this one's the best also to us
burger king you can get a soft serve
cone i didn't get it only because
we have no refrigeration unit here and
it would just be a cone with a puddle of
ice cream so victoria please turn me
into a giant soft-serve cone
so here are our drinks let's start with
this one this one is ginger
and fanta melon
oolong tea
which is chinese tea
and orange juice
and this one is
earl grey iced tea
next we have darjeeling tea
and here is calpis
which you guys call it
kyle pico in your country but japan we
say karupi
i know it sounds like cow peas in
english but if you say calpico to
japanese people
they will never understand what you're
talking about so in japan once again we
say karupi
repeat after me
karupi
very good
first things you can get you get a
little orange juice guy
and you can also get
capri sun apple juice shout out to the
pouch burger king in the u.s has coke
products as well but we have something
called the coke freestyle machine if you
haven't seen this big machine that has a
bunch of coca-cola related beverages you
can mix and match them anyway we can get
hi-c fruit punch hi-c pink lemonade
fanta orange mellow yellow powerade zero
dr pepper barks diet barks you can also
get yourself a fat-free milk
there it is sweetened or unsweetened tea
i think i got the sweetened i don't want
any tea
tea sucks we also have something called
frozen cokes that is this right here as
you can see it's been sitting for a
while starting to separate but we have
frozen coke you also have a frozen fanta
wild cherry a frozen phantom blue
raspberry and a frozen strawberry
lemonade
oh yeah japan has a few exclusives that
are similar but different to that in the
u.s so for example this is our
plant-based whopper
this burger is made from 100
soy beans
it's actually delicious i like it
when it comes to vegetarianism and
veganism they are not that popular in
japan but gradually especially the
restaurants in tokyo are offering more
vegan or vegetarian meals because there
is more japanese people and non-japanese
people who are vegan or vegetarian
compared to other places in japan but
overall the vegan or vegetarian option
is still limited in japan and in the u.s
we have the impossible whopper what's
the difference well the impossible
burger has all these ingredients so as
you can see a lot more
i am curious well that looks like meat
right
tastes exactly like a whopper i don't
think i would notice the difference
they're covering the lack of meat with
like with that shower flavor that they
have on there
oh that's good
in japan we call this burger crispy
chicken burger
and the us we have the before mentioned
chicken sandwich which comes in
varieties of spicy and or deluxe
for breakfast our hash brown comes in
one big piece
whereas in the u.s
our hash browns come in little bites and
in japan we have this
cheese bites
look at this
and in the u.s we have eight piece
cheesy tats well
and on to the u.s breakfast exclusives
as you can see we have a lot more going
on in our breakfast menu here in the u.s
than japan has here in the u.s you can
get your breakfast sandwich and biscuit
or crew sandwich options chris sandwich
is of course a croissant sandwich took
those two words put them together for
sandwich so we have
bacon egg and cheese
ham egg and cheese
and
sausage and cheese
we have two
breakfast burritos the eggnormus
breakfast burrito which i'm assuming is
this one cause it is
enormous
the breakfast burrito junior look at
this little guy
french toast sticks who doesn't like
french toast
finally pancake platter with just three
pancakes or a pancake platter with three
pancakes and a side of sausage
[Music]
the fries at burger king in japan come
in three sizes
small
medium
and large
fries in the u.s at burger king come in
four sizes value small medium or large
or maybe it's value small medium large
does this look right any of you food
wars heads would have seen the burger
king us versus uk episode where we
uncovered fry gates two sizes had pretty
much the exact same unit of fries now as
you can see from these i can't tell
which is the value and the small i'm
assuming this is the medium well
unfortunately we cannot do
that amazingly accurate scientific test
that we did in the last episode because
the fries have been compromised they all
came in the same bag and
i think they knew what we were up to and
they purposely dumped all the fries in
the same bag to contaminate the
experiments you've outsmarted us this
time let's wait a large price to see how
much you actually get
151 grams what if we did a thing where
like whatever lands and stays on counts
counts does that seem like a fair thing
to say that's really smart what i just
did there i think
it's 195 grams
let's weigh japan's whopper
250 grams and let us weigh our whopper
in the u.s
270 yeah 270 grams so pretty cool
surprisingly close
if you're not feeling like having beef
burger king also has some chicken
options you can order your chicken
nuggets in five pieces and eight pieces
here in the u.s you can get your nuggets
in sizes of four pieces eight pieces or
16 pieces and it's worth noting that you
can only get the 16 piece online or
through their app and even if you do
they still just give you two eight
pieces i don't know why either
so let's weigh eight piece nuggets
130 grams
divide by eight equals
16.25 grams
per nagging i don't know if we can get
as accurate of a measurement for
something so small so we will use
this guy
instead
so i'll just do this and put the scale
up here
ah
this is a bad idea eight pieces is
104 grams
divided by
eight is
13 grams
in japan we have three drink sizes
small
and medium
and large
in the u.s we have four drink sizes
value which only comes with a value meal
small medium and large now i want to
note that the us's largest drink size is
112 larger than japan's largest drink
now what's the biggest meal you can get
in japan's burger king over here it's
the king
meal
the king meal ranges anywhere from 790
to 990 yen depending on the burger you
choose it has your choice of an avocado
whopper double cheeseburger or whopper
we chose the double cheeseburger which
comes with small fries
five piece nuggets
medium coke and apple pie
and in the u.s currently our single
biggest menu item at a burger king is
the 30 ultimate party bundle now you can
only order this party bundle through the
bk app and it includes two whoppers two
double cheeseburgers two original
chicken sandwiches two eight piece
chicken nuggets four small fries and
four small drinks and it costs
thirty dollars
in japan a warper tea set it costs
around 890 yen or seven dollars eighty
cents us
where's in the us the same meal with a
small frying drink is 9.29
or
1059.65 japanese yen what about the
medium if you get that the medium fry
and medium drink it's 10.29 or 1173.71
japanese yen what about the large
poof hey there it is right in front of
me large fries and drink
11.29 or 1287.78
japanese yen
let's look at calories in japan a
whopper is 676 calories the calories
aren't too bad but watch out for the
sodium labels one japan whopper is
113 of your daily recommended amount of
sodium
too much
in the u.s our whopper is 667 calories
both whoppers are pretty comparable in
most of the categories but there's one
statistic that really stands out the
salt content the sodium level in japan's
whopper is
122 percent higher than that in the us
let's make that a meal a whopper with
large fries and a large coke it's 1 323
calories
and the same meal in the u.s is
1680 calories so a lot more now a big
portion of the calories actually come
from the large coke the us's is roughly
182 percent more calories than that of
japan let's look at the highest calorie
sandwich at japan's burger king the
double whopper cheese is here eating one
of these is already half of your daily
calories and a little over your daily
recommended protein the main thing to
watch out for here is the sodium which
is
152 of your daily recommended volume
whereas in the us our highest calorie
sandwich is the spicy chick king deluxe
sandwich seen here if you're worried
about your health steer clear this one
the fat content is 190 percent your
daily allowance and the sodium is over
200
of your daily allowance yikes
as i mentioned earlier the biggest menu
item is the king meal if you get it with
a double bacon cheeseburger the total
calories are 1 329
that's 66 percent of your daily calories
and of course the 30 ultimate party
bundle which is
8903 calories or
445
your daily caloric allowance
[Music]
burger king in japan doesn't disclose
the exact ingredients but it does
disclose where the ingredients come from
and where they are finished processing
for example the whopper beef parties are
sourced from australia new zealand and
europe but they are processed in
australia japan and austria
burger king in the us is pretty vague
when it comes to its ingredients they
don't disclose a comprehensive list
anywhere at the end of 2020 burger king
permanently banned 120 artificial
flavors from their menu including
aluminum yellows 1 through 5 bha and bht
here's the complete list
it was actually a lot of stuff
good for you guys